to sync your plan cast calendar you'll
need to get your unique calendar url
here's how to do it
sign into plancast
go to profile and click calendar feed in
the right menu
click ical and copy the link
sign it to tungleme
go to management and select synced from
the menu
click add new calendar and contact sync
source
and select plancast from the pop-up
name your calendar paste in the link you
copied from plancast
and click add source
your plancast calendar is now synced
note that the tungleme sync with
plancast is read-only
that means you'll be able to see your
plan cast events and tunnel me and your
availability will be updated as you add
new events to plan cast
but tell me will not be able to add new
events booked through tumble me to your
plan cast calendar